[Music]
although a liter battle angel has only
been running in cinemas for several
weeks a sequel is already in the works
this is at least what director roberto
rodriguez recently set a precondition
for this is of course that the first
film runs well and this seems to be the
case at least up to now since 140
million of the 170 million u.s. dollars
in production casts effort raised so far
mainly in the USA so if the first part
is successful abroad a sequel is almost
guaranteed as the end leaves a lot of
room for a second part we will probably
be able to say more about it in a few
months time but so far the forecast
looks very pleasing the second most
successful Chinese feature film of all
time will soon be released on Netflix
it is a science fiction film called the
wandering earth which was released in
Chinese cinemas on February 5th and has
already earned 600 million u.s. dollars
and even though this film has been shown
exclusively in China and hardly a film
fan has heard of it
Netflix secured the rights to the very
successful blockbuster and will soon
make it available for the rest of the
world the story is about the apocalyptic
scenario of the dying Sun which will
expand hundreds of times and destroy
every life on Earth therefore the earth
is supposed to be torn out of orbit by
gigantic engines in order to save
mankind sounds exciting and also what
special effects will be offered sounds
huge in addition to over 10,000 perhaps
purchase especially for the film there
will also be more than 2,000 special
effects shots so at this point we don't
know when the film will be released on
Netflix but what we can expect as a
science fiction spectacle similar to
interstellar another two more seasons
will be shot for the Big Bang Theory
spin-off young Sheldon u.s. channel CBS
is quite satisfied with the series about
the young Sheldon Cooper from the Big
Bang Theory since fall 2017 young
Sheldon regulary reaches 10 to 12
million viewers which is not much less
than the Big Bang Theory with 13 million
viewers per week the spin-off has
mutated into a saffron and that's not
that surprising after all the Big Bang
Theory is in its final stages at the end
of the 12th season
by the way fans of the young Sheldon
Cooper can look forward to fog this year
because this is when the third season
will air in the USA there are some news
about the Lord of the Ring Amazon series
planned for 2021 the advertising is
slowly to get started since Amazon has
recently launched its own Twitter
channel for the series on which a map of
middle-earth was also published last
week and this contains some clues and
secrets about the Lord of the Rings
series the posted crowd 7 for the draft
Lords in their halls of stone should be
familiar to every Lord of the Rings fan
another fan also claims to have
discovered that the map which was
mentioned dates back to the second edge
of the talking universe before the Lord
of the Rings movies and it was in this
very age that the rings of might
reforged which is an indication that the
series could be about the creation of
the Rings in combination with the quota
but for 12 Lords it is also possible
that the focus will be on the dwarfs
another rumor is that the series will
deal with the story of the young Aragorn
we can't yet clearly check which one of
these rumors is true and which one isn't
but it's certain that the rumor mill is
boiling and that soon even more secrets
about new promotional material will be
revealed by Amazon after the rather
moderate reactions to the plan streaming
service Disney Plus there are now new
rumors from the Marvel and Star Wars
universe in addition to the Star Wars
series the Mandalorian there will be
also other exclusive Disney content in
order to gain more customers for example
there will be a series about the young
Princess Leia and a series with Rose
Tico as the main character how those
streaming service will ultimately
attract users with exclusive content is
questionable however the first
foundation for this new place has
already been laid with the Mandalorian
serious by the way this series will be
released at the same time as the
streaming service in autumn 2019 and
will start with 10 episodes with the
Punisher and Jessica Jones Netflix now
sells also the last two films of the
Netflix Marvel Corporation the reasons
are certainly diverse one of which will
be that the production company's ABC and
Marvel Entertainment now want too much
money another is that Netflix will now
focus even more on films made in their
own
production and probably the most
decisive is the already mentioned
streaming service Disney Plus which
wants to secure all Disney and Marvel
content on its own channel in direct
competition to Netflix many fans are of
course not excited about this and fear
an increase in illegal downloads and
they are right to do so because who
wants to pay for five different
streaming providers an animation series
for the video game and in isolation from
2014 will be created seven episodes are
supposed to be released which will
probably get the edge rated 18 plus the
release date could be already in April
and also be free of charge on the
official alien website sounds good at
first since the 2014 alien survival
horror game which is based on Ridley
Scott's film alien the eerie being from
a foreign world received good reviews
the crux of the matter is that there is
no official statement yet the chance
unlikely at a release in less than a
month but could also be an advertising
flyer to heat up the fans so we can be
curious if we will be surprised with the
release overnight or if there will be
official announcements from the alien
team
[Music]